i was just this lanky asian nerd who
played chess aaron maney he's one of the
uk's most successful ever youtubers
i was getting some sort of sick thrill
out of seeing the numbers go up so i
made one video every single day for at
least six months it drove me to the
point where i one time i just broke down
crying on camera um i never published
that but i have a i have a photo which i
sometimes look back on to remind me of
like
what it took
there's some things about you that you
can't fix and i think you just have to
be very mechanical about them and be
like this is me i have good things and i
have bad things but the bad things i
can't change i'm gonna lean on things
that are good about me fix the things i
can fix and
the rest is life
emotionally physically just exhaustion i
think is how i'd put it very very tired
it was actually a bit of a pivot point
in my career because i sat down like
this isn't actually what i wanted it was
a realization that i've actually you
know my channel's growing all these
metrics are looking up but but this
isn't you know
my brain
not many people know this actually but
[Music]
aaron maney he's a creator and
entrepreneur with over 8 million
subscribers
his story is unconventional a young kid
from the uk that was bullied in school
and whose path to escape that reality
would turn out to become his dream
his purpose
his meaning but as aaron will tell you
he made the critical mistakes so many of
us make when we're chasing our dreams he
became obsessive he sacrificed too much
things that mattered more
and at some point that would lead to him
having a breakdown and that breakdown
was a moment of inflection and he's
figured out that all-important balance
of striving while knowing that you are
already enough at the same time and that
i guess is the ultimate goal of all of
our lives
so without further ado
i'm stephen bartlett and this is the
director ceo i hope nobody's listening
but if you are then please keep this to
yourself
[Music]
aaron
tens of millions of followers and
subscribers later um when i read through
your story and your journey i could see
this real sort of
fundamental obsessive
um ambitious
guy under there and it made me wonder as
i was reading through about how obsessed
you were with the growth and
the scaling of your channel it made me
hypothesize that there must have been
something happen in your early years
that did that to you that gave you that
bug that
insatiable desire to be successful or
something have you identified what that
is
yeah uh
so i'd probably i should preface this by
saying that
i'm very aware i'm a very lucky person
um i actually just got off from my
brother's wedding a couple of days ago
and
i was just looking around at the the
family around me the friends around me
thinking like
damn like you know this is it
um
but there was one thing so
when i was growing up i had a very
supportive family but i didn't have a
great school life you know i was i was
just this lanky asian nerd who played
chess that was that was me basically um
and i think there was some part of me
that did seek approval
and uh i mean all this really happened
when my brother got me my first
smartphone and that just became my
outlet
you know on one hand i had this school
life that was very very mediocre but
then i had this this piece of technology
in my hand that could do all these
things and i just became obsessed with
it like this was my life
yeah i guess um and i just poured
everything into it i learned everything
about this phone and how to do all these
things on it and i think it just got to
the point where i was like let's make a
video
how old were you when you were you were
that you described yourself as a lanky
asian kid that got got a smartphone for
the first time how old are you 14
probably yeah and and the school you
went to
what was the what was the what was the
typically people get bullied because
what you're leading to right i've heard
you talk about being bullied i think in
some of the interviews you've done um
typically people get bullied because the
other kids think that there's something
to bully them for
yeah uh there was plenty um i was a nerd
uh i wasn't very pretty to be honest
like people regularly just call me ugly
um
i think there's some sort of also
subliminal thing about being asian not
being like a cool thing
um it wasn't like a particularly asian
area if that makes sense
just i think a lot of things add up into
you just being a bit sidelined
was it a predominantly white school
predominantly yeah i did have asian
friends
but majority of them yeah
and so you get given this phone and that
becomes your world
yeah what about your your parents your
your
immediate family
i mean that they're amazing they
there was obviously a little bit of
questioning at the start you know when
you're sitting in your back garden and
you should be revising but you're
shooting earphones and you know it's
like a bit of sun what are you doing um
but as soon as they saw the kind of the
potential in youtube they've been
just like all for it
did they understand what it was
yeah i'm quite lucky like my parents are
very entrepreneurial they're very modern
like they've done it themselves they're
also business owners so like
they get it you know and were you were
you an entrepreneur from
an early age outside of the obsession
with tech
yeah
i've done the usual like you know like
maybe selling sweets in the playground
and
young enterprise i don't know if you
know what that is but um
i was like the managing director in our
school for our young enterprise team and
i had this big idea of like we were
going to create a stylus that we were
going to pitch to tesco and sell it to
them
and we created the stylus we created the
packaging it was beautiful it looked
like an apple product but
i think i was the only one with the
vision and i didn't do a good enough job
of getting my team to believe in it and
so like
one man can't sell a product to a
company like that especially not like a
16 year old boy at school
wow
so you were okay you're trying to pitch
your tesco at 16 years old um
your family in terms of monies
how were they were they
reasonable yeah you know when i was
growing up like it's not like we had
everything like i couldn't just ask for
what i wanted but you know we had enough
um and i can't complain to be honest i
think there is a benefit to having
things somewhat held back from you
like i think it makes you appreciate
when you do have things i mean you've
had the same right yeah yeah yeah and
you so you sign you cite that um sort of
search for validation as
being one of the real driving forces
it's the same with me same in my life
it's like i talk about this in my book
at tremendous length i think
that feeling like i didn't fit in
created
like it was almost like pulling a spring
back made me fly off into the world as
an adult trying to validate myself
through like material things or
followers or like i don't know some kind
of social approval or whatever
you're you're saying that that's the
similar
i think that was the that was the
springboard
but i think it's very different to that
now
like
i'm no longer insecure about who i am
i'm i'm confident in myself
and so
i'm almost like immune to people telling
me that they like what i do or almost it
doesn't even register because i kind of
like i'm internally quite self-aware
about it
um so now i do things because i i want
to do them
so you get given that phone tell me how
that leads to
youtube oh well it wasn't a great phone
it was like it was pretty low end and so
like
my goal in life at the time was
basically to get it to score a certain
amount on a benchmarking app
and so i did everything i could to this
phone i was trying to like overclock the
processor and all these kinds of things
just to get it to hit this score
because in my head that was like that
was the sign you had a good phone
and so it led me to to just customize it
in ways that people probably wouldn't
have gone like extreme lengths
and that just through that i just gained
knowledge i just understood it and i was
fascinated by it
pretty smart kid if you're playing with
like the processor of a phone at 14.
i get i guess
so how were you academically
pretty good actually i think
without blowing my own trumpet i think
every exam i've
you know every exam i've sat i've got
the highest marking so
what sort of topics were you um
particularly interested in when you were
younger
i was quite mathematical there was
something about so i did maths and
further maths as two of my a-levels and
to start with there was an element of
you can feel a bit lost in those
presentations when you're getting taught
because if you miss one line of
reasoning you you lose the whole thing
but when it all comes together when you
finally understand mathematics
it's there's nothing quite like it like
it's its own rule set
and
you can prove things in ways that are
completely indisputable
and i just i love the language
and so a lot of my background is
actually economics i went to do an
economics degree
and i think that completely changes the
lens for which you view the world
you can see things instead of being like
lots of gray areas you see things in
black and white oh this is why that
person is doing that thing oh this is
the next logical step for my business
right
and and so you go to university
okay in the pursuit of what career
uh yeah so i was about to become a
consultant at pricewaterhouse right
i did like an eight-week internship
there at uni
and uh got the job
um
but probably the turning point was
actually when i turned down that job i
had to write up this little email being
like had a great time really enjoyed it
but actually
no
so youtube has been kind of like
building up in the background since the
age of 14 15.
and throughout uni i was still doing it
but it was not at a stage where it was a
comfortable career path
but it was an exciting career path and
so i had this had these two kind of
crossroads i could have gone down it was
either the traditional route or the
youtube route and
one side was just was just fascinating
to me it was you know this whole new
world the sky was the limit and i
thought it's got it it's got to be that
one
and when was the first time you made a
video was when you were 14 and you first
got that phone pretty much yeah take me
through that growth journey then so you
start what was the first video
oh gosh uh it was how to optimize the
zte blade
which is the phone app okay i'm just
gonna say yeah and and is that still on
online yeah
and how did that video do
at the time
i'm sure some people have gone back and
watched it yeah i think
yeah if you looked at it now it probably
has a couple of hundred thousand views
because of people who've gone back and
looked
at the time i just remember being blown
away by the reception i'm sure if i
actually knew now what the views were at
the start it wouldn't be very impressive
but
i couldn't believe that even a thousand
people were watching it
you know if i if i thought about my
circles at the time i was thinking
things in terms of single people
and so when you see a number like a
thousand you're like oh my god
and and how long did it take before you
hit that
a point where you thought [ __ ] you now
this is
this is going really well
i thought it was going really well when
my first video hit 5000 views you know i
remember showing my friend at his house
and he's like that's not you come on
behave yourself that's not you well yeah
as in like he's like there's no way you
got 5 000 views oh right okay yeah so i
mean i i was very i guess maybe it's
part of that whole
i had no validation at school meant that
my bar for what counted as validation
was pretty low
you know like when people said they hit
a hundred thousand subscribers i'd watch
other youtubers i never dreamed of that
like i never even thought that was an
option
i was just kind of doing youtube to get
a few thousand clicks i guess
do you think that um
your youtube journey has
given you because you said now that you
feel like you're a confident person do
you think youtube has done that
yes
but only if only because i've been quite
proactive about it so youtube is
it's a really incredible thing in the
sense that like
in no other career path can you get such
immediate feedback
like when i post a video within one
minute there might be 10 000 people
watching it there might be a thousand
comments or 500 comments and every
single one of these data points how many
likes and dislikes it's got
that is a piece of data that tells you
how you're doing
and so like you can grow so quickly as a
person as well as a channel if you know
how to harness that data companies would
kill for it
it sounds like emotionally dangerous
for the crowd to be giving you feedback
on who you are
potentially you develop a thick skin i
think as you go through it providing you
have the right mindset and i think as
long as you can filter out the
negativity there is data hidden in those
comments like you almost have to strip
away a layer
and and just kind of take what's useful
is it it sounds easier said than done to
avoid the negativity i mean like most of
the guests that i've had on the podcast
when they speak about negative comments
and these might be super successful
celebrities in their own field
they still admit to being triggered more
so than they should by just that one
that one percent negativity versus the
99
blowing smoke up ass
yeah so i think it it depends on if it's
something you're insecure about
so
if i'm insecure about i don't know let's
say the
the shape of my face and someone makes a
nasty comment about the shape of my face
it's going to sting it's going to sting
a little
but like because i think over the years
i've grown confident about most aspects
of myself
i think i stopped worrying about the
negative comments because i'm i'm okay
with who i am yeah i did a did a
question tag on instagram this week i
said if i could write a book for you
what would it be about and one of the
most popular things was confidence so
what advice would you give to
um people listening that are low in
confidence about how to build build
their confidence because
telling that you know i was thinking i'm
telling them all to build like a 10
million sub youtube channel is probably
not
probably not attainable for everybody
but
i think you have a very similar opinion
to me on this which is that
you need to make it input based rather
than output based you can't pin yourself
to a certain number of followers or
anything so that you are confident you
have to make internal peace with
yourself
and i mean
i look around on the street like all the
fans that come up to me and they're like
oh can we get a photograph with you
you're incredible i love your videos i
look at them like you're incredible as
well look at you like what are you doing
you know you've got a camera you're
snapping photos of buildings show me
that looks incredible
um i think everyone has their own story
and their own great things about them
and people struggle to see it in
themselves
but they can see it in others
and i i can't like there's no person on
this planet who i would look at and
couldn't see good in them and couldn't
see something great
if you were that young kid again that
that was lacking in confidence at 14
years old and say i couldn't give say
you couldn't do youtube so it didn't
exist
what else might you have done knowing
what you know now about how your
confidence has been built what else
could you have done to reach the same
outcome
i'm really trying to get to like the
what what is it that made you
come to peace with yourself
um
because
because it sounds like it was a lot of
people
being nice
after some weren't so nice when you were
younger
hmm
i think i'm quite a i'm quite a
proactive person so if there's something
about me that i don't like i will try
and fix it
um
so a lot of people not many people know
this actually so when i was younger i
used to have like a crooked nose
and it bothered me a lot i used to like
only sit at certain angles from people
and you know i'd hide myself in the
corners of rooms so people couldn't see
the other side
and
eventually i was just like this is a
solvable problem why am i worrying about
this so i just got i got surgery done
and fixed it and i think
there's there's some things about you
that you can't fix and i think you just
have to be very mechanical about them
and be like this is me i have good
things and i have bad things but the bad
things i can't change i'm gonna lean on
things that are good about me fix the
things i can fix and
the rest is life
so on that point of having a good or bad
nose this is me just going with the wind
now because i find it super intriguing
um something i've thought a lot about um
who who who was to say that your nose
was bad
people would laugh at me
so i guess others
it's interesting
society says you know this is not good
about you
is there a risk in then changing to
please them do you think because i feel
like that might be a slippery slope
yeah yeah
it
hm
it is a slippery slope but
you just need to know your limits
you just need to kind of like
set the boundaries
maybe that's easier said than done yeah
yeah because i i really want i wonder
that a lot about cosmetic surgery these
days just generally and about the um
[Music]
i'm always i'm always like if someone
gets one thing done then there's always
a
there's now a new most like there's now
a new worst thing about me and why don't
you then go and get that thing changed
then that thing changed and i i wonder
if it's a slippery slope i have no data
data to back this up but just
anecdotally from seeing some of my
my friends who've got one thing done
they typically then will get another
done and then
i've seen it too i've seen it too you're
right um
but but there's also an element of like
if something bothers you to the extent
where you're having to have this whole
other layer in your mindset of like oh i
can have a conversation with this person
but i'm going to do it from here
and you can fix it fairly easily
then you you should do it like if the
next thing then becomes oh well i'd
quite like my chin to be longer you're
not really solving a fundamental problem
you're just you're just you know having
fun
that's personally where i would draw the
line because obviously i don't think i
have the perfect face or the perfect
good looking guy oh thank you very much
um great asian hair great
yeah us blacks don't have it the same
way necessarily people like beard yeah
just no effort on my part it just
happened
yeah it's strong thank you very strong
um i was gonna so
one of the reasons i was asking that
question about confidence and how you
build it build it is because i reflect
sometimes on a lot of the stuff that i
say and i think i put out there
especially my book in my podcast that i
like did this internal work and suddenly
i found my confidence and the
insecurities faded away but i can't get
away from this idea that i did also make
myself mega rich and successful
and get millions of followers and that
might have played a role in me being
able to like shrug off the insecurities
easily so i'm wondering if like and what
awful advice it would be to give to a 16
year old kid to have to say to him oh
you you're lacking in confidence well
just go and build a multi-million pound
business and get 10 million subscribers
on youtube and then you'll be fine
yes that's what i'm trying to unpack is
it is it the achievement and the
validation from the achievement that
helps the insecurities fall away or is
it some other type of
internal work
i think i think actually gratitude plays
a big role in it um
i've spent a lot of time recently
trying to wake up each morning and just
remind myself i feel like we are we are
hardwired to focus on the bad things
because
i mean what prehistorically those used
to be the more urgent matters
and i think gratitude fixes a lot of
these insecurities because it's like
okay yeah i don't have beth the best
skin i've got acne everywhere but hey i
can breathe that's incredible
um so that is something i've been doing
a lot of and i think a lot of the
personal growth i've seen has come since
then
what does that look like practically in
terms of practicing gratitude
so one thing i do is when i wake up i i
told myself i was going to write down a
few things but i end up just thinking
them but that's enough so i think of
three things that i'm just grateful for
in that moment and oftentimes you end up
saying the same things again and again
but that's actually that's okay
it's fine like you don't need constantly
changing
um mechanisms to keep you happy
i found that recently with some of my
friends that have been not so well i've
just had this tremendous gratitude for
my health watching one of my friends
that's younger than me
be have a
really serious illness
and it's crazy they they say the same
about like hospital awards if you walk
through a hospital word you'll suddenly
feel this tremendous sense of gratitude
for your health you know and um how do
you practice that on a daily basis
without having to have someone fall ill
or go to the hospital
i think is diff increasingly difficult
especially in a world where everybody's
like status signaling every time you
open your phone
you know how do you how do you go about
doing it then yeah it's really
interesting i i make a conscious effort
that's the first thing but i don't
remember to do every day
and then um
music does it for me sometimes which is
really strange
um
and i i'm very fortunate that i think
naturally i have these like waves of
gratitude that come over me i'm very
aware that i am current and i said this
in my my live show the diversio live i
said
the vast majority of this audience
you're currently living a dream that you
once had but you're not appreciating it
because your current self is telling
future you that you'll be happy when you
get
three times more than you have now
that's typically up and down the income
and wealth spectrum what people say they
need to become a 10 out of 10 happiness
is 3x what they have right now
and it's that and it's that idea of like
you'll never therefore be happy because
you're always so for me that really
centers you and says [ __ ] me like 18
year old steve this is what he and i
when i say get goosebumps again like
this is what i dream for yeah like i
wanted to be financially free so that i
didn't have to steal chicago time pizzas
and nick chicken bones from takeaways
and look at me
i'm 28 years old and i'm free
you know like yeah so i try and
sometimes that plays out in my head
naturally
um
you get this a lot on youtube like
because of how numerical the platform is
like i i distinctly remember moments
where i'd look at my sort of like
statistics and be like oh imagine a
hundred thousand subscribers imagine 500
000 subscribers i would dream of those
numbers
and uh you almost don't quite realize as
you toddle past those numbers in reality
because you're already ready for the
next thing
you're so focused on like uh making it
even bigger even better getting that
phone even earlier before launch and all
these things
you have to stop yourself do you stop
yourself be honest with me are you
successful in that
i'm really happy yeah i'm a really
really happy guy um
so i i'd like to think yes i didn't used
to be even even three four years ago i
didn't used to be
um when i graduated i
had this pent up energy from youtube
because i've been doing it throughout
but i was also juggling it with my
studies and i wanted to get a first and
i also didn't want to have a terrible
social life so i was doing all these
things and it was kind of this this
crazy whirlwind of just kind of like
activity to activity jumping between
filming to lectures to homework to
nights out
and so when i actually graduated i was
like right i'm gonna give everything to
youtube
so i made one video every single day for
at least six months and it it drove me
to the point where i one time i just
broke down crying on camera
um i never published that but i have a i
have a photo which i sometimes look back
on
to remind me of like
what it took
um
and so that that reminds me
why were you crying
it was uh
a lot of things that sort of come to the
fore
it was it was exhaustion in the moment
because it was it was really hot and i
was just kind of like my hands hurt and
my voice hurt my throat was cracking
but it was also this kind of long-term
build up that led to it
um
it was it was actually a bit of a pivot
point in my career because i sat down
like this isn't actually what i wanted
um
it was a realization that i've actually
you know my channel's growing all these
metrics are looking up but
but this isn't
you know
my brain
and it made it immediately made me
change mindset from hard work to smart
work
it was i suddenly started thinking like
do i which tasks do i need to be there
for
and
how do i make sure i'm only doing those
tasks
and also it made me take a step back
from i'm not doing a video every day
i've gotta look at the data look at
these retention graphs find out how to
maximize the click-through rates all
these kinds of things it allowed me to
take a step back breathe
and focus on how to utilize my brain to
the best of its ability
in terms of mental health you tapped
your head then when you said you'd
optimized for i guess youtube
performance but you hadn't optimized for
your mental well-being
at your lowest
what was what was the what was what
state was your mind in
your well-being
i've never been depressed i would say i
think i've i'm quite resilient as well
as being quite lucky
um
but
i got to a stage where
emotionally physically just exhaustion i
think is how i'd put it very very tired
to the point where i didn't have time
for
friends for family like by the time i'd
finished they were asleep
um
i'd kind of screwed myself into a little
hole and that hole was my bedroom
where i'd film
so i think that's what people call
burnout
yeah yeah but i wouldn't let myself stop
because i told myself that like this was
my dream and that one video a day was
the way to achieve that dream
and so like there was just something
inside me which is like you can't stop
now like you're there this is this is
the runway just
run what did you tell yourself your
dream was
i would look at other youtubers when i
was a kid and just like you know
they had like a million subscribers for
example
and they were getting all this tech
through the door and their entire job
was to just test it and learn about it
and i remember just being like that's
the best thing in the world like i'm
fascinated by technology i would love to
be able to just see all this stuff
because when i was younger i didn't i
didn't get to play with the latest stuff
you know i was i wasn't the kid who had
the latest game boy or anything like
that
um
so so i guess that really appealed to me
so your idea of happiness when you're
younger was getting sent amazing
technology and being able to just like
do what you love talk about it so you
you
i guess you set yourself this plan of
just being making a video every single
day
in the
i guess the thought that that would lead
to your your dream and i guess you you
you realized at some point that your
strategy was
unsustainable
yeah good way of putting it yeah it just
felt like a really like you still wanted
the same goal but your strategy in terms
of getting there was just unsustainable
oh my god it just i relate to that so
much in so many different ways and i
think
a lot of people don't realize that you
have to set up your goals as marathons
not sprints if you you do want to
achieve them right yeah i've never heard
it described like that but that's it
yeah yeah
you've got your whole life to do these
things like it doesn't need to be today
and potentially the intensity of trying
to do it today
is actually the biggest risk to it ever
happening yeah because i mean if you if
your mental well-being had
been adversely effective more adversely
effective than it was you might not have
ever come back to youtube because of
yeah i mean it could have been enjoyable
like you it sounds like
at that point when you were doing that
like just crazy sacrifice everything
was it enjoy was it was it fulfillment
or was it something else
i was getting some sort of sick thrill
out of seeing the numbers go up the
sixth round yeah
but you know when it comes at the cost
of yourself i think you've been there as
well yeah you're not enjoying it really
and it's that thought in your mind that
i can't do this forever yeah but it took
until a kind of breaking point for me to
realize yeah and it seems to you for a
lot of people
it seems that a lot of people hit some
burn out some explosive moment i mean
tom blonfield sat here from the podcast
ceo and founder of monzo and talks about
the same thing just waking up in the
morning with like a sense of dread
and
like his sleep actually being
the peaceful escape in that three
seconds when he woke up and he didn't
realize he was the ceo of munzo just
being amazing
and that crushing weight of like but it
seems to be the case with a lot of
people that they don't they get so
caught up
in this this hamster wheel chase for
their
dream that they don't realize it's
unsustainable and the cost it's having
on other things that are
fundamentally conducive to living a
happy life yeah people
people yeah i think we are
we are complex beings but we are also
quite simple in what we need
and that social interaction and
people who are close and who actually
want us to succeed
and we don't need many of them
we definitely don't need 10 million
tell me what you thought you needed
before and then after that moment
so before so tell me what you thought
you needed in life before you had that
sort of breakdown moment and then what
you've come to realize in subsequent
years that you actually need in life
hmm i think before it was very much a
numbers thing i think i was a i was a
kid who thought that the answer was just
to just keep growing for the sake of
growing
but but afterwards it's very much been
about i still want to grow i still want
to be the the best tech influencer on
the planet i want to be synonymous with
the word tech
but
it will be mindful growth it like one of
the factors in that growth will be not
just monetary but it will be
does it work with this does it does it
still make me equally or more happy
no decision will go forward if it
doesn't
if that makes sense so the goal hasn't
changed but the the approach has
it's fascinating i think a lot of people
can relate to that in their lives um in
a lot of ways because they're
essentially sacrificing a little bit too
much and trying to
win a sprint but these big goals like
the goals that you have the ambitions
you have they are as we've said like
marathons
they are they are um i'm very aware that
like if you want to be the best in the
world at something you've got to give
something you can't spend
you know all your time with your friends
just having beers you you have to let it
go sometimes and so
i'm very
i'm very careful with how i spend my
time
but i make sure that there is quality
time with the people that i do care
about
so and so let's talk about that point
then hard work a lot of people say that
hard work is um
it's toxic
etc what do you say to that
oh the whole uh
wake up at 4am that that kind of
attitude yeah
yeah i don't think that's the way
forward if anything actually i think
sleep is uh a really practical
productive thing to be doing um
if anything i wish i was better at it i
actually struggle a lot with my sleep
i'm really trying to improve i've
actually got your um episode with the
sleep expert on my watch later oh god um
yeah um no she she says some really
important things i'm not watching on the
way home yeah yeah um
so i'm not of that opinion i think there
is a time and place for really hard work
but it has to be for a cause that
it has to be for the greater goal
um
yeah i think i think you talked about
this with uh on the episode with ali
yeah yeah yeah yeah and what was the
conclusion you came to well i i can't
remember exactly um what we came to but
my general thinking on hard work is that
um and and i guess burnout is when
you're doing something that you you can
where you consider the reward of doing
it meaningful and worthwhile then hard
work really is important and i actually
listened to elon musk this weekend to
talk about this he said the exact same
thing he said when you believe that
you're doing the correct thing and it's
a noble or like meaningful goal then
hard work is really really important and
it's also will help you
avoid burnout but when you're doing hard
work for a task that you don't think is
meaningful like working in a factory for
14-hour days and it's and it's not
stimulating your mind and it's just hard
work for minimum wage yeah burnout is
inevitable and it's just around the
corner and that for me is like oh god
that's my idea of a nightmare
hard work hard meaningless work
for me is being is the definition of
like
lose your [ __ ] marbles insanity i
think i'm very lucky in that sense in
that like i found my calling yeah and i
think we're in a world where a lot of
people just don't
i'm not saying that there's like one
true goal for each person like no one's
going to have their dream job
but i think a lot of people they find
out quite late what they really enjoy
and i think we're in a system where
people have to decide very quickly
um and with not a full information set
what career path they want to go down
what advice would you give to people
that are i mean this is just again
talking about things that people ask me
all the time how to find my passion or
whatever is
so i would say
try as many things as you can while
you're young
um i had a really close friend who's 18
and
she
decided she wanted to do pharmacy
but then did two weeks of that course
and was like actually
i don't really want to do that anymore
um and then was like oh maybe i should
do medicine so she dropped her to
pharmacy thinking about doing medicine
and then she might drop out of that
decide she wants to do business studies
it's like
if you just spend two weeks in as many
different careers as possible that
that's when you know um
there's
kids kids are lazy a lot a lot of kids
are lazy and i think um
there's this kind of short
short-sightedness that you have to just
kind of find a way to overcome just for
your long-term future sake like that
time is so pivotable when you're
deciding you're sat at that crossroads
and you're looking down all these
different paths
given the systems we have in place you
have to spend that time well
finding out which like what these paths
actually look like
um
and the system as you say set up at 16
years old they give you like brochures
and they're like pick yeah pick which
subjects you're going to do and then
you're like oh [ __ ] then you're locked
into those subjects then they go which
university in which course and you have
no idea the medical and the law courses
are particularly bad because they're so
specialized
um you know if you do a medical degree
you're not really qualified to do a lot
of different things like you're probably
going to be a doctor
and you can very quickly find yourself
in a position where you feel trapped
i have another friend who did medicine
and then did the whole thing but then
was like actually no i want to be a
journalist
and so that whole five years they didn't
need to do it
how did you find your calling then so
what is it and i don't mean because i
know your story we all do
but what is it about you that when your
calling showed up you had the whatever i
don't want to give i don't want to put
answers in your mouth
to say
that's it
i'm gonna go in that direction because a
lot of people wouldn't see playing
around with mobile phones as a
uh
possibility
i would say uh light in the dark um
it was very obvious to me because of
what the alternatives were
like
i was kind of i think a lot of people
follow the path
and the path basically dictates that the
subjects you are strong in you study a
degree that is similar to those subjects
and then those degrees usually have a
next stepping stone and a next stepping
stone and you'll just kind of you'll
shoot down unless you veer off you have
you have to actively veer off that path
and so i was very much going down the
kind of i'm strong at maths therefore
i'm going to do an economics degree i'm
doing i'm doing an economics degree so
i'm going to be a consultant i was going
down that path
and i'm just i was just lucky that i was
also doing this other thing which
excited me so much
and so comparing the two when it became
clear to me that actually youtube could
be a career as well
um
it was just an obvious choice
do you ever reflect on what might have
happened if you didn't have the
conviction to go for
i think i think i would have become a
consultant which is terrifying
i i wish i could say i wasn't but you
know that's the work experience i did
that was the job i was offered
so
given there was no outside option i'd i
probably would have taken it
and a lot of people have done that in
their lives they've followed those sort
of sequential steps yeah and ended up
somewhere
and they're listening to this right now
and thinking [ __ ]
it's tricky because you don't want to
just quit your job one day for a you
know potential startup you might have
with a 10 chance of succeeding you can't
you can't do that
right like what advice do you give to
people in that situation well this isn't
about me
no but i i really do i really do i
always say what you said at the start
which is about just increasing the
amount of experiments you make as as
like
cost um cost-effective experiments
you're making as young as you possibly
can which is exactly what you've
described which means go to another
country spend two weeks and quit really
[ __ ] quickly yes and just like rapid
quit the minute you're like i hate this
quit move on try in and i think people
that are exposed to as you say the most
data the most information are able to
make more informed decisions about what
they enjoy and you can take that part of
that job where you got to do this thing
and mix it with this part of this job
where you got to do that thing and
slowly weave your way towards the thing
that gives you the most fulfillment yeah
but as we say i know because i know the
people that listen to this podcast
there's so many people right now in jobs
where they've kind of like ended up
there working in kpmg or pwc in the city
wearing a suit and tie
and they know that job isn't for them
they know it's not for them
but they they just maybe they you know
but there is also an element i think of
like
we live in a society where social media
is prevalent and people log on to
instagram every day and see other people
who are leading better lives than them
or apparently yeah
and i think there is an element of
gratefulness with the job you do have
because not everyone is going to find
their dream job and maybe the job you're
doing is your dream job because it
facilitates the life that you currently
lead
does that make sense it does yeah and
that's like this the practical approach
i'm not practical and like people will
get mad at this but like look at that
look at my decision-making i stopped
going to school i then dropped out of
university after one lecture started a
company quitter out out the blue ran
another company for seven years quit out
the blue i make decisions based on how
i'm feeling and practicality has always
been secondary in terms of well what am
i going to do about the feeding my like
dropping out of university manchester
never got a student loan
i'm shoplifting these chicago town
pizzas and i call my mom and say mom i'm
dropping out she goes i'll never speak
to you again i didn't care because i i
was just in this relentless pursuit of
me of what made me feel good every day
um so i understand the practicality
argument but i i find it dangerous
because it hints of like
just tolerate it
you know like yeah but but let's say
like obviously i'm still fairly young
but i can imagine that if i was 50 years
old with a family to support and a
career that i'm not you know i'm on the
fence of i'm like well you know it's
fine it's good you're right
what can you do like you just got to be
happy with it i do say to people you've
got to be practical in those moments but
i don't think you've got to be happy
with it if you're not
you shouldn't quit you can look for
outside options but i think it's not one
of those things to be impulsive about
i agree yeah what we're describing is
there's this middle ground yeah where
you have to be practical because your
kids need to eat
but and so you want to be more strategic
in how you you know you make your move
however i don't i really don't want
anyone at any age to find themselves in
a place of like
misery
and think well
gotta be grateful and i've gotta feed
these kids haven't i i just i just want
better for people and i know it's hard
like i know it's hard or else everybody
would just be living their dream but i i
also know
that it is possible
for
all of us regardless of age or position
we find ourselves in or how stagnant
we've been for how many decades
to make the decision today that this is
the start of like the rest of our lives
and we're going to just give it a
[ __ ] go
i know that's true the only thing that
stands in the way of that is people
don't believe it's true they look at you
and you seem so far away 10 million
subscribers you must be superman super
genius that
born with it parents must be rich you
must have genius just that's not me
i'm a muggle
and i hate that
because i'm you know
and yeah yeah everyone starts from zero
every youtube channel had zero
subscribers at one point and you know
was was cheering when they got the first
one and it was probably their mum you
know
the most the most inspiring thing i
think i could show the audience is
probably you and you're 14.
do you know what i mean because they'd
be like that guy the same with me they'd
be like that [ __ ] guy i had the
camera presence of a vegetable
[Music]
not good
that's crazy on this point of friends
then
and relationships how are you doing and
and what are your tips you're super
ambitious you're scaling this big
business um on youtube
what are your strategies to maintain
meaningful relationships amongst all
this chaos
because i struggle
yeah i
i try and make sure it's quality time so
i think i spend less time texting and
more time seeing people like if i spend
two hours texting one of my friends that
is much less of a quality connection
than two hours of seeing that person of
being able to have a fluid conversation
and being able to see them and see their
facial expressions and their
gesticulations and all that
so i pretty much plan my time such that
the minute i finish work i am doing
something in person with the people i
care about
whether that's a board game with my
family or a night out with my friends
that there's very little down time but
in a good way
do you have to be somewhat of a
contradiction in
who you are to
have
quality relationships um you have to be
a different guy because what i'm saying
is professionally everything is about
return on time if i spend one hour what
am i getting back do you have to be a
different guy to get the most out of
your social life in terms of
that
that sort of like time efficiency i'm
the boss
yeah it sounds very transactional to
look at relationships like that
um
i think every person actually does view
them in the same way they just don't put
the labels on it
i think really we're all doing the same
things as humans where you know we've
got a set of 10 decisions in our heads
things we could do and we pick the one
that's best for us
but i think i just attach a framework to
it that allows me to think about it
easier
so i think i'd be doing the same thing
even if i didn't think about it in that
way
i'm just the way i think about it allows
me to plan it better
and you value those things you now value
those well when i when i finish a day of
work and i know i'm about to go see my
friends like my heart starts punting i
get so excited
i just like i get off the station at st
pancras sometimes and i just i feel like
uh like a free bird
and like i know there's going to be a
little adventure that weekend and it's i
think those moments make your life worth
living do you have a lot of friends
not many but but they're good ones
roughly how many
i have i'd say like good friends like
brothers like you know what i mean six
sisters six six years and that's pretty
much my entire circle i think the only
friends i have are good friends
the rest of them i've almost decided
that realistically i'm not going to be
able to make this friendship work and
it's sad like sometimes it's even just
geographical some of my friends after
university they
they move to france or indonesia or hong
kong
and just the fact that they're in
another country has meant that
realistically
my friendship with that person is just
going to be a series of messages hey how
are you doing i'm good how are you doing
and
even though i like these people
it just doesn't work
that's not like a meaningful
relationship is it you must have had the
same thing as well 100
yeah and it's really frustrating because
great guys but you know
do you know i actually struggle at the
moment because my girlfriend lives in
indonesia
and so right now um the border to get
into indonesia is closed yeah so you
can't get in anyway and i can feel that
my relationship with her is like
small talk
you know it's like oh hey how are you
i'm doing this what are you doing today
i'm doing a podcast again and running my
business what are you doing yeah running
my business it's like do you know what i
mean
and you can feel that the the importance
of like physical one-on-one time
um which has been smashed because of the
pandemic but also
because she lives literally 24 hours
away
so i've got to like really reassess my
life
i'm assuming you've tried like video
calls and like video messages and
even then it's like different time zones
and
yeah that's the worst
oh my god it's really difficult
but you come back to this point like if
it's worth it you're gonna
go to extraordinary lengths to figure it
out figure out how to solve the problem
and for me that that means that i'm
gonna have to go there a lot i'm gonna
have to fly to indonesia a lot she's
gonna have to fly here a lot so you see
that being like a permanent long-term
relationship
yeah
crikey
yeah good luck i know right she's not
indonesian she's from france french and
portuguese she's just making your life
difficult
no comments
um but if it's worth it you got to put
in the work and you know i reflect on
all of my friends relationships and this
is the really the thing that really
makes me want to put in the work to make
it work is all of my friends even the
ones that have had the most successful
relationships have been through hell in
chaos at some point they've had to
overcome really really remarkable
challenges and it's overcoming those
challenges that have made them stronger
so
i see it as that like my friend that i
consider to have the best relationship
out of all my friends they have
individually both been through personal
chaos and managed to come come out the
other end
so i see this as a as one of those
things like a test like the board is
closed you can't get into the country
you know like that uh what's that rocky
balboa quote it's not how hard you get
here it's how hard you get here and
can keep going forward i think that's
relationships and the thing that keeps
you going forward is like
is it worth it
is it worth it
yeah at some point the answer to that
question might be no same with burke
so your chance uh your stance on this
has changed hasn't it with relationships
yes
quite recently
which part
which part of my stance so i remember
reading that uh
you had a relationship that you had to
kind of like end because you were so
focused on your work oh that i think
that daily mail wrote that um but i mean
that is true that is true with all of my
previous relationships pretty much
yeah
um that was just a young naive kid that
was like a super naive version of me
that was
miscalculated miscalculated the
priorities of life
and what changed was it just finding the
right person or was it an internal thing
it was
definitely both but i'd actually say it
was more the internal thing it was the
this is why i asked you the question
earlier on about you what you valued
before and after your breakdown because
before
for me before i had my sort of turning
point i thought as you said the most
important thing in the world was just
getting rich buying a lamborghini and a
mansion and then having loads of like
infrequent casual partners i thought
that would be it that would make me
exponentially happier yeah um what i
came to and i didn't think relationships
mattered friendships or romantic
what i came to learn
through a variety of different stimuli
one of them being a ted talk i saw where
they did a 100-year study of men and
they looked at men that had
relationships and men that didn't have
relationships the ones that had
relationships lived like 10 years longer
were healthier happier
imagine that lived 10 years longer crazy
made them physically healthier
were happier
everything everything that mattered
was given to those that had meaningful
relationships then i read lost
connections by johanna hari and it shows
that a lot of the reason why we're
getting more and more depressed and
socially anxious and all of these things
is because we're not in our tribes we
don't have meaningful connections but
[ __ ]
and then i looked at what i'd been
feeling myself
and i'd always i'd always been too
scared to say i was lonely i'd always
been too scared to say that
and i've always been too scared to say
that i wasn't feeling good either
but on reflection now i was lonely i was
really really lonely you can be lonely
even if you're surrounded by people yeah
100
i think actually
there's a reason why a lot of people say
that university is the best time of
their lives and i think it's because
they're surrounded by friends and
the relationship people have with their
friends is often healthier than the
relationship people have with their
families because the level of
expectation is removed
like i think with families people find
that they fall into certain roles where
like they do the dishes and they clean
the floors whereas at university with
your friends if you clean the floors
you're here you're a hero
and i think that kind of that attitude
means that people want to hang out with
their friends more and they enjoy that
process even though they're
fundamentally doing the same things
they're being appreciated more 100
and i think
i try and apply that in my relationships
it's like
when my friends come to see me just the
fact that they've come to see me i'm
like oh guys come on amazing yeah it's
amazing
there's also new hierarchy in friendship
groups in terms of like your family you
have a hierarchy you have the older
brother and the older sister then you
have the mom in the and then you also
get to typically select your friends
which you don't get to do with your
family so you can wind up with a pretty
nuts family that's true and have to
tolerate it because you are related and
i think the friendship especially as you
get out of school because school kind of
forces you together but if you get out
of school you start to discover who you
are what music you're into what
interests you have you then build a
tribe around you that have shared values
and that seems to be the best
yeah the best tribe not to underestimate
family though like i think when you have
good family connections
no one wants you to succeed more than
they do yeah yeah yeah and i think very
few people have your best interests at
heart
apart from them 100
what about romantic relationships have
you found forming romantic relationships
as a
on-screen mega youtuber
ambitious guy entrepreneur nuanced is
what i would say like
when you
when you have this whole youtube thing
clearly like
people are into it right people it's a
cool job if nothing else it's just cool
so you're saying women are into it
yeah yeah yeah um
but i think
you'll know when you've found someone
who
looks through it looks past it
um the only challenge then becomes time
because youtube is not just incredibly
time consuming but it's also
unpredictable and so in relationships
where people want stability
trying to offer that stability is
is not easy um you know let's say
someone wants me to come to a wedding in
two weeks time aaron can you definitely
make it can you book that date in
i can't i can't really
you know i'm i'm not
i'm not working a nine to five i can't
book days off sometimes an opportunity
presents itself and it's such a great
opportunity that i don't want to turn it
down
um
like like this chat like you know i i
really wanted to come see you as soon as
i got the email but had i said to
someone else a friend or a girlfriend or
whatever that i was going to be doing
something with them this day i'd have
had to i'd have had to do that and that
that horrifies me
because you know we're in a place where
the sky is in the limit all these
metrics are looking up and so many
people and opportunities are presenting
themselves i want i want to do them all
so how would you balance it how do you
balance it well
quality time in person time and i think
so you almost have to kind of like
assign things in your relationships an
importance level
and if something is really important to
your partner then you just be there no
matter what
if things are somewhat negotiable then
you know try and make it but don't
commit
and how important is it to find the
right person i'm guessing you've
potentially tried a few different types
like i have i've tried a few different
types of people maybe and maybe three
three or four maybe five
no
like i mean like relationships over the
last
over the last uh let's say 10 years
different different characters that
either saw my work as a threat
or saw it as a really cool thing and
were supportive were maybe way too
supportive or maybe
way too intimidated by work how
important has it been to find the right
person
so important so important i mean you
know your partner is the person you're
spending you know you want to spend the
rest of your life with they're going to
become you effectively
you know you've heard that thing where
you kind of you become the five closest
people around you yeah yeah your partner
is going to be your biggest influence
for the rest of your life and so them
being on the same page and them being an
inspiration to you as well as you to
them i think is
is the only thing you need
do you think you need a partner that is
ambitious and i always i always find
this really fascinating that i've had so
many conversations with very ambitious
entrepreneurs um
and they tend to go one of two ways they
they typically tend to believe that they
also need someone who is sidetracked
with their own dreams and goals
but i i question that sometimes
and i think okay so start with
yourselves
well so
okay
so
when i was a little bit more stupid
like 18 i used to think that i want my
partner to be
a like a philanthropist has has their
own thing
and to just be
you know taking over the world
themselves
however
in reality i've come to learn that i
might be lying to myself because
if that were to be the case
then we'd probably never see each other
right
um because the likelihood is they'd be
in another country doing massive things
and it would just be texting
and so i've i've come to learn
especially when i was in the height of
my career at social chain and i was
flying like 50 days a year
50 weeks a year sorry um
i couldn't have possibly had a
meaningful relationship with someone
that was doing the same
so it's made me question myself a little
bit and start to reflect on the fact
that especially when you know other
factors come into play maybe i need
someone that is going to be a little bit
more
uh supportive of my of my and i don't
this answer gives a [ __ ]
i think i think where i am
at with it is a little different i think
fundamentally the person you end up with
has to see eye to eye with you they have
to be on your wavelength and i think for
people like us who are just so
incredibly ambitious we want to do huge
things with our lives
it's not going to work out with someone
who isn't like that because eventually
you'll lose respect for them
so i think all these things about
convenience of the relationship they
kind of all fall to the wayside
if that person
is right
if they if they see you
like that
i've been unable to form a romantic
relationship with someone that doesn't
have passion for something and i'm not
saying take over the world i mean like
be inter-knitting like
love you know anything just like love
like dog breeding i don't like in
reading grooming just just be passionate
about something and i think what i'm
looking for there is
to come home and talk about you and your
life too and your hobbies not just uh
it's a center on me because then i don't
get to escape i don't get to relax and
wind down you know yeah
um now you're right yeah it doesn't
matter what they're passionate about but
they have to be passionate
yeah
but what if they are what if they what
if they're flying 50 weeks a year how
had you
how does that work
i think in the same way that like you
know you have to compromise for the
other person they will also compromise
for you yeah and i think it's okay if
you make a million less a year or
whatever it is depending on what scale
you're working on if it means you can
have this meaningful relationship
because as we've established like as
humans we need that it's a core need and
it's the easiest one to neglect because
the feeling isn't as urgent as hunger or
thirst but it is there
so true
so true i definitely have realized that
if i'm gonna have a romantic
relationship and it's gonna work
i'm going to have to leave millions off
the table
just like in
missing meetings and not and having to
compromise and that's a really
that's a really interesting hard to do
because you then try and quantify the
value the relationship has as a return
and you say well if i'm probably going
to lose
i reckon i'd lose
like five million a year by having a
romantic relationship genuinely maybe
even more like genuinely probably more
yeah and you think oh [ __ ] oh they've
got to be worried
but then you reflect and go i'm
i don't need more money do i yeah but
there is a game to be made in terms of
like romantic
connection yeah beyond a certain point
what what is money it just it's a bit of
convenience right that's all it is
and potentially if you get too much
a pain in the ass right yeah like some
people like i know they spend they spend
a long time looking for things to spend
their money on oh god that's the worst
yeah that is a sickness
yeah um so i got this uh phone through
the mail not that long ago and it was a
hundred and seventy thousand dollar
iphone
but you know what it was it was uh so
not an iphone it was a samsung phone but
it was a phone with a gold brick
attached to the back
and i was thinking to myself what kind
of person actually buys this
where would you have to be in your life
to purchase this particular phone
miserable bastard you've got to be
miserable yeah
right you've got to be miserable
i can't imagine a world where someone
that's buying a phone that has a gold
brick strapped to it is living a
fulfilled life except everything i must
know must be wrong if they they can buy
a
gold bricks oh do you want to know the
funny part so because of the gold brick
on the back the cameras don't work
[Music]
the way i reasoned it was that if you've
got that much money you've probably got
someone to take photos of you true yeah
or you've got no friends because you're
that miserable what money then let's
talk about money what what role does it
play in your life
so when i was growing up um like i said
i wasn't underprivileged so i had i had
all everything basic covered but there
was definitely what things i wanted you
know i wanted the latest toys i wanted
the latest trading cards whatever it was
um
so when i first started getting income
from youtube
i was very happy with it you know i
would buy things off amazon and like
make myself short-term happy just fill
those little gaps that i had in my
childhood i guess would you go looking
for things to buy sometimes yeah i think
i would same
um
it's that first initial feeling of
freedom and like
it almost doesn't feel real when you can
order things off your own card and like
they come to you and it's like i've
earned this this is my treat
um but after a period of time i realized
that like the things that i actually
want don't cost very much
and so i actually i've purposefully not
bought myself a nice car because i
actually i'm very aware that as humans
we adjust slippery slope it's a slippery
slope and i know that
even if let's say 20 years in the future
i own a ferrari or a lamborghini there's
no point rushing to get there
because i know from that point all i'm
going to be thinking is what's next
and so you might as well get a polo
first and then maybe get an a-class
mercedes and then maybe get a a nice
nissan i don't know work your way up
even even if you could get a nice car
now like what's the rush
just enjoy the journey it's like i see
it like a video game like do you play
many games yeah
so
i always find myself when i play games i
am rushing to finish them and i want i
want to get to that last boss i want to
beat it for the final reward
but then as soon as i do that i just i
lose all interest in the game
and it it there's so many parallels
between that and real life
you know what do you do when you have so
much money that you don't know what to
do with it you just you find things to
do with it and that in itself is is a
you know
it's just another thing to do
it makes me feel sick
sometimes that i still have these
moments where i will like glance at a
mansion on like right move and then i
genuinely have this sick feeling in my
stomach because i know what my life then
means
do you know what i mean like genuinely
it would probably make me miserable
because i'd have to move out of london
which means i'm further away from
friends and people can't come to me and
then i'm in this eight bedroom house
yeah that no one can come to you anyway
and i feel that sickness
it's like nice i feel the same way when
i look at like the lamborghinis and the
rolls-royces which i always come back to
i'm going to buy one it's like the
insecure kid shows up and then i get
that like belly sickness where are you
going yeah it's like well steve if you
do that you know what this means yeah
yeah you know what treadmill you're like
there is some part of you that's pulling
you and you've got to be like stop yes
exactly and it's that insecure kid
that's being still being influenced by
society and social media to try and run
at those empty things yeah it's actually
something that's been on my mind
recently like society it's that it's
that thing and
through adverts and social media
targeting like it's found its way into
our lives in a way that is so close to
us all the time constant that you're
being pulled in this direction
and it's no one's fault it's not our
fault
um
but we are becoming very materialistic
yeah at the expense of things that
actually matter yeah and it is at the
expense of something else yeah these
apps are are custom built every decision
made with these applications that we use
is built to use us
to to extract from us
um every chime that goes on is custom
built to to mess with the the parts of
your brain that are made to sort of like
they're made to make you lose control to
make you think oh my god there's a
notification i've got to check it
they're built like that and that's
terrifying
so what you do about that knowing that
uh
i used to use a scheduling app so i used
to set my phone up so that all my
notifications would come at one point in
the day interesting yeah um
but then i stopped doing that when i
started missing important emails
so now i just kind of keep my phone on
silent and look at it when i look at it
i almost get mild anxiety if i've not
checked my whatsapp like what you mean i
used to really get it when i was at
social chain because
especially when i was living in new york
city um i would wake up
after guessing that's right yeah i'd
wake up after the uk so i would know the
minute i woke up and i'd usually wake up
at 4 a.m because my brain would wake me
up because it was anxious
knowing that the minute i touch my phone
and look at all these offices around the
world and all these people and all these
employees and these directors
my phone every morning would be
70 80 messages
so you'd wake up and then you go like
with one eye open reach for the phone
and look and just check there was
nothing on fire like no major crisis
yeah yeah yeah and doing that for
man it takes out if you don't want to
get up you don't want to do your job
anymore yeah you don't you don't want to
ever have that again it's it's awful how
did you get around that i didn't i quit
the job eventually but it was it wasn't
up until i quit like i was waking up
with that
that like con i was always as you know
at the worst times when the business was
like stuff and it was it would struggle
like i wouldn't want to open my emails
and i wouldn't want to open my whatsapps
it was just because you knew it was bad
news your body's conditioned it gets the
signal it's like if you press this
button you get bad news why the [ __ ] do
you press the button then yeah you start
avoiding pressing the button yeah yeah
yeah so
yes it's it's um it's not easy but
social media is designed in that way
it's like
for probably more so from like the
positive reinforcement you get from that
dopamine hit of getting comments or
likes or whatever and as a youtuber you
must feel that more than
more than most you've got yeah 10
million it is on my mind actually that
like
what other things i do in my life going
forward are going to give me the same
amount of dopamine because if you post a
video and it starts you know hitting
trending and it's getting millions of
views and so many likes and 10 000
people telling you you're great
what tops that
what what am i going to do in my life
that is actually better than that
um
and and i do sometimes i've had to kind
of pull myself out of this mindset but
there was a point in my life where i
would look at situations i was in let's
say on bowling with my family and i'd be
thinking like is this making me as happy
as getting a viral video
it's not it is a slippery slope
because it's almost too good
it's too good and nothing else can match
it
it's kind of what you said you said
earlier about playing the video game and
waiting until you get to the end you are
your standard of that dopamine hit or if
a thrill is so high now yeah yeah it
must be hard to meet that elsewhere in
life yeah
so what do you do about that
how do you how do you how are you able
to enjoy and you don't have to have the
answer we're all works in progress
you'll be 25. but how are you able to
enjoy other parts of life with your
partner who wants to just go to i don't
know go shopping go shopping or have a
picnic um
i think the key is is detoxing every now
and again you've heard of the whole like
dopamine detox not really
so it's the idea of completely depriving
yourself from all stimulation for
periods of time
so
no music no phone no internet nothing
just very simple pleasures
and so like whenever i get the
opportunity to do those i will take them
and so like i have these periodic
moments of complete release where i'm
doing nothing stimulating and they're
quite difficult to be honest like the
urge is definitely there to run up and
check my notifications but i refrain
just because i know long term like i
need to stop
and how long are these periods of
dopamine detox
it's whenever i i can afford to do them
i mean i think in a best case scenario
you do it regularly but for me it's more
like
if i finish a big stint of work and i'm
just exhausted i'll say okay next day
and a half
i'm doing i'm doing very little
i'm gonna talk to people and
um
drink coffee
you know and what impact does that have
i think it brings you down to earth
again it reminds you of the things that
are important and it allows you to enjoy
them
you only need a couple of hours and i
think you can very quickly start to
appreciate things that you'd forgotten
to appreciate before
because you were caught up on social
blade statistics
is there we talked a lot about the
positive sides of this um meteoric rise
you had on youtube and how it helped you
like be a bit more secure in yourself
and understand yourself a bit better but
are there some
character characteristics or
um
i guess side effects of this that
are probably reversible now that you
irreversal yeah like irreversible
consequences of this meteoric success on
youtube
that
are negative in your view
i mean that that was kind of one of them
there but yeah it the only thing that
comes to mind i suppose you'd almost
have to ask the people around me to get
a proper answer but the only thing that
comes to mind is how cagey i am with my
time
i think because of how much i plan it
and
because of how self-aware i am of how
important it is
i i very much find myself in situations
where i'm like okay this was great gotta
go bye
um
and i do really enjoy these break times
but i do also cut them
um and i think for other people who who
aren't as cagey with their time they'd
probably see that as like uh he's got to
go again classic aaron you know
or rudeness or something maybe yeah i've
been told actually a few times in the
past that actually like i start a
conversation realize i don't have time
for it and leave um i used to do that at
university because what would happen is
you know you go out your room you're
living with your friends you talk to
someone and before you know it there's
seven people in the corridor chatting
yeah and even though i was the one who
started the conversation i'd have to go
because i'm like okay at 7 30 i've got
to start scripting youtube yeah um and
some people will be like well that was a
bit rude
which i can understand but there was no
other way i could have got what i needed
to get done done
you don't regret that though do you no
i don't i don't regret it because i
think the people who have ended up as my
core friends they they understand
i tend to also believe that the people
that have reached fulfillment and
success their lives are really they have
like a high boundary set for the use of
their time at the end of the day as i
talk about a lot um it's the only
resource we all have yeah allocating it
in a really efficient manner towards
things that matter
i think is important but a lot of people
won't they'll find themselves in that
hallway conversation and they won't want
to be rude because they're people
pleasing so they'll end up spending like
two hours talking about things they
don't care about with people they don't
really like yeah yeah yeah yeah and for
me that's a just a cardinal sin of like
happiness you can't
you've got to be a bit of a i was going
to say the c word then i shouldn't do
that you've got to be a bit rude
sometimes you've got to be rude
sometimes yeah
i think a lot about that idea of like
becoming uh the richest man on earth but
then being really old and
wanting to spend all your money to buy
another day or something
i think about that a lot and it it's a
constant reminder of like stay in the
right lane focus on the things that
matter you don't have that long
do you think you're lonely now
no i don't i did
a few years ago but i i feel really good
now i feel like i i know what i want and
i've got it
and that's that's comes from the balance
of friends and family and romantic
yeah connections yeah not many but but
good ones
you've um you've grown you know this
youtube channel over the last what ten
years ten years roughly
um from zero to
over eight million subscribers in terms
of your growth trajectory
what story does that tell
um
how quickly you grew how exponential was
that an s-curve was it slower than fast
it's been
pretty much slow then fast somewhat
exponential i'd say so right now um
i my channel is growing much faster than
where it is proportionally so the the
percentage growth on my channel is
really high like one of the highest on
youtube
um
and i've only actually got a team of two
people in total to be honest so i'm at a
stage now where i'm thinking okay i need
to get more help i need to get more
people doing the things that i shouldn't
be doing right now
but i want to keep it as me like i'm
very aware that like
i could probably get more numbers if i
had people writing my script for me and
stuff but there are certain things that
i just want to do because
i i like them and i think i'm good at
them
um
and so i want to keep doing those things
but in terms of that that sort of
exponential growth how long like give me
the time frames in terms of how long it
took you to get to several different
stages okay i've got a tweet actually i
can find it find it for me okay
so
it took me seven years to hit one
million subscribers it took one year to
hit two million
eight months to hit three million six
months to hit four million and then
three months to hit five million
so that there's there's definitely been
a sort of you know a curve hockey stick
yeah
but but i think people they kind of
misplace where that comes from i think
people have this idea that if you're big
on youtube you'll just keep getting
bigger on youtube
but i think what actually happens is
that you're big on youtube because
you're starting to understand what works
and therefore you get bigger because
you're implementing what works
if that makes sense
oh 100 i mean that's applicable to every
walk of life right as well as you were
saying i was thinking about
everything
thinking about the gym and i was
thinking about you know your business
yeah yeah everything
um
it's interesting
it's interesting because there are a lot
of youtubers who get big and then stop
like their growth stops
yeah they they build these big channels
and then the tectonic plates shift the
algorithm says okay we want something
else now and they
fall off and they i don't think a lot of
these are actually algorithms changing i
think right from the start the
algorithms have had a very simple goal
and i think they've been able to achieve
that
i think that's
the creator's losing touch
it's it's whether it's failing to keep
up with the competition because the bar
for content is rising all the time
or whether it's just neglect of what
their audience wants like sometimes i've
seen creators who
they get big and then they're like oh
this is what my audience wants to see
i'm just going to keep doing that exact
same thing the whole time or sometimes
you get creators who one minute they're
making a video about how they make
cupcakes the other time they're making
tech videos and
you've got to keep your audience at the
front of your mind because
so have you heard this saying that like
create what you want to create and your
passion will show through and people
will find you no okay because i've heard
it a lot and i actually strongly
disagree with it because i think it it
makes the creators think that like
they're the prize they're the customer
when actually it's the viewers
and it's a privilege to be able to
create for them but you can't be
complacent about that they're not going
to come to you just because i'm making
stuff i like making there's too many
people who are doing that for that to be
the case
so you have to really respect people's
time and really deliver value to them
in order to be able to adapt to what
your audience want
it's got to be a two-way conversation
so how do you have that two-way
conversation really i know how you have
it one way but i'm saying how are you
getting how are you understanding what
they want what are the metrics you're
looking at is the comment section is it
and again these aren't just lessons for
youtube these are lessons for anyone
creating any product in the world that
is looking to build their customer base
because it's the same business
so there's both there's explicit and
there's implicit feedback the explicit
is someone literally writing aaron this
was a great video or aaron you should
sit a bit further back because your face
is too close to the camera i've had that
that's very useful
but the implicit feedback is is what is
most of it it's what percentage of
people who watch this video put a like
on it it's what how like
how many minutes of this 20 minute video
did they watch and at what point did
they drop off that's an incredibly
useful piece of information there and i
used to actually as soon as i changed my
attitude from work hard to work smart
these are the things i started looking
for it was like oh i said this sentence
and there was a drop there i'm not going
to say that sentence again clearly that
was doing something and it was trying to
understand what about that sentence made
people drop off that allowed me to grow
as a person and as a channel
so are you really in the weeds like that
you're really looking at every video and
i'm obsessed with it yeah it's my
background as well like i'm a math
student i'm an economic student i love
the data
um i think to some extent the fact that
i pay so much attention to it is one
thing that really helps me over other
youtubers oh i can tell i can tell
because the answers are there it's the
same in business your customers are
usually telling you what they want or
don't want but we lead with our
hypothesis yes and with and our
hypothesis is ego uh attached to our
egos it's sometimes overly romantic so
we can spend years as i think i did in
my first business trying to sell my
customer or who i thought my customer
was
a
product that they didn't want and when
they told me they didn't want it because
of their behavior you were like no i
tried to sell
it was actually when i started a
facebook group and realized that the
facebook group was
50 times 100 times more um
effective in achieving what i was trying
to achieve with my website
that i was like people want to do this
behavior on facebook i'm trying to force
them to do it somewhere they don't want
to do it
just go with what the people want and
that requires you to be
low ego low romance
there is one caveat which is that
every now and again people don't know
what they want
you know like if you think about the
first iphone that came out right
people at the time if you'd asked them
what they wanted they would have said oh
i want a flip phone with maybe a bigger
keyboard and they would have just kept
saying that year after year
but but actually the iphone completely
changed what they wanted
and there is a time and place for that
as well in youtube sometimes just you
have this idea no one's asked for it but
you just think oh that's a good idea i'm
gonna try it and you'll very quickly
realize if it's the right thing to do
it's harder to
argue with the um well i guess when
you're creating something new there
isn't the data there isn't the
pre historic iphone so that's why you've
got to just do it try it's got to start
with an experiment and then go into
analytical observation yeah i guess
i guess that's a good uh good approach i
think everyone can relate to what are
some of the biggest misconceptions of
you as a youtuber that you that you that
piss you off
uh there's a big thing with tech youtube
where like if you say a good thing about
a product or a company the assumption is
immediately that you're paid to say that
and i think it's an element of like i
probably just need to communicate better
how it works like i'm not paid every
time i say a nice sentence about samsung
they don't just like slip me a couple of
a couple of bills
that's that's probably the predominant
thing i i saw somewhere that you send
these companies an email when they offer
to give you a product you letting them
know that you won't accept the money
but you will review it if you like it
yeah so a lot of the emails i get are
actually would you like to do a paid
review yeah and i i can't with with the
with an honest conscience say yes to a
paid review because
it's a contradiction a review is a piece
that is meant to end with a
recommendation you should buy this or
you shouldn't buy this and having taken
money for that piece
you can't be objective no i can't be
objective
so there are cases where yeah a company
said can we pay you for a review i've
said no i'll do a review but i won't
take i won't take the money so how do
you make money
so you can do sponsors if you do
sponsors in the right way so what i
think is the right way is
i will take on sponsorship if it is
if i don't have to be conclusive about
it
if i can be completely genuine about it
like like you'll for example um i do
sponsorships with you but that is
because i was drinking fuel before he
all reached out to me
so they actually spotted me wearing a
hue t-shirt in one of my videos and
they're like oh okay
this guy he likes it already would you
like to talk about us and i said yeah
why did you like heal
do my sponsored
genuinely why did you like your
it i guess it fits in with my lifestyle
i uh you know being
i care about my time
i um
i'm not getting paid for this no i know
i am
cheers
yeah go on why don't we
no
no genuinely i'm i'm really really
curious as to why why it fit in your
lifestyle it was the same for me i was a
customer for three years
before
they sponsored the podcast similar thing
they were looking for authentic
influences but
i'm curious as to why it um it fit your
lifestyle
i think it's this idea of
a meal is sometimes
for enjoyment but it's also sometimes
just because you need something to eat
and uh when you're very busy you don't
care about
what it is like you just need nutrition
you and you just you don't want to be
eating crap basically you know you want
to just eat something that you feel
good about
and that's what this was
i had a friend who got me into it
but he he was actually using like full
fat milk when he was doing it the whole
time and he was wondering why he wasn't
losing weight
i was like try it with water just give
it a go um yeah i don't even have the
time to do the
well i do the protein but i don't i've
i've never really been a huge fan of the
like powder in the in the cup mix so i
used to do that and then as soon as i
started having the ready to drink ones
now i just have these yeah same because
they're in the fridge they're chilled
there's no washing up
exactly yeah yeah have you tried the
protein
yep you have i like the strawberries and
cream oh yeah it's on top of my fridge
over there yeah anyway so as you you
know you've achieved a lot in in
business but also on youtube you've you
know
i i got youtube channel i've got like 50
000 subscribers bear in mind like 90 of
my audience listen off off youtube
um
but if you told me that one day i'd have
eight million subscribers
i'd wonder where my motivation would be
to get to try and get more
i think well that's [ __ ] i mean nine
that makes no difference
yeah ten like
what is your motivation now what is it
where does it come from
i think it's this idea of like
i feel like i have a message to share
almost like tech is fun tech is exciting
and
it's it's one of the few industries
that's moving forward really fast
like like i look at fashion and you know
things just go round and round in loops
basically but but tech is tech is a
straight line
and so
i always like the idea of just getting
people on board with that idea
and so
becoming synonymous with the word tech
and becoming someone who's like a
teacher of tech and who who's a a fun
place to learn tech
that's kind of where i'm at right now
so i guess my my end goal would be to be
the tech person
so when someone says tech you think oh
that's aaron meany that's uh mister
who's the boss you know he's tech go
look at him
so you
one of your central focuses is becoming
synonymous with the word tech um
globally on youtube as a teacher and
educator what about the other facets of
your life your personal life what are
your
what are you aiming at
i think to be honest like the things i
actually want are fairly simple all
these considered like it's not cars or
or
money or gold brick phones it's uh it's
just good good happy well if you're not
using it then
it's going to ask if you still have that
you've got to send it back
i actually do still have it you still
have it okay they they asked me to send
it back initially but then
communications got mixed yeah i bet they
did
but they couldn't they if someone sent
me a gold brick phone trust me can you
yeah i'd stop answering
they couldn't get a career who could
insure it so we're struggling to send it
back basically i send it out i got a
good guy that sends the phones back send
it over here i'll i'll take care of it
send it over here
i've got i got a guy that's
yeah
best career in
europe
yeah um i watched actually one of your
past podcasts where you talked about
like the idea of
we trick ourselves into thinking there's
something on the other side but this is
it
and
i'm very aware of that and i'm very i'm
very happy about it
i don't need anything else like i'm
enjoying the process and
as long as i can keep having those times
when my friends are over and we're
playing video games together and we're
laughing on the couch and you know i can
spend good quality time with my parents
going out for dinners
that's all i need
but then going back to a professional
goal about being sometimes synonymous
with tech if you were to achieve that
goal
what would it do for you
put a smile on my face
probably not much more i'm gonna be
honest like i think goals like that
they're not meant to be achieved in a
way like
just having the goal gives you a purpose
like i already have the income i need to
to have the social life and the kind of
like the things that actually make me
happy and so this goal is something to
give the rest of my life a purpose
and it is a goal that you can almost not
measure
yeah
which i know is against all uh
goal-setting
uh it's like it's against goal-setting
101. i know you're meant to have like
smart goals and all that but um no i
think it's great i think more people
should have goals that are i said this
on my instagram the other day
incompletable because that gives you
that stops you from that sort of
mountain top moment where you then need
another goal
to find your orientation in life and to
find your direction so those big
incompletable goals i think are the best
well you can't ever measure if it came
true yeah um
which i i think is i think is amazing
but it's but it is interesting that
achieving the goal would basically do
nothing for you
yeah which is crazy when you think about
it but but i'm loving the process
you know like so every time an article
gets written about me or i get
referenced or someone shares it
i look at it and i'm like oh wow this is
a step towards my goal
so even if i never achieve that goal and
even if when i do achieve that goal or
if i do achieve that goal i don't care
that much
it's created a structure such that i can
really enjoy the process
and that's probably the probably the
secret to
professional happiness i guess isn't it
it sounds like a it sounds nuts it
sounds crazy to have a goal you can't
complete and that doesn't matter
yeah it does i can see it could you
imagine that books the key to being
happy is to set goals you can't complete
that don't matter
that don't actually matter um but i
think you're left with no other choice
when you get to a point where you've
ticked off those maslovian needs of like
food shelter security yeah that's
exactly it
nothing beyond that point really matters
there was a point when i was like oh if
you get 100 000 subscribers you've made
it you've done
and so when you've got 80 times that
there is a point where it's like this
isn't
numbers don't make you happy you realize
that quite quickly
well listen
thank you so much for uh being so honest
and open with me today i've had such a
um enjoyable diverse conversation with
you and it's a it's an honor to get to
meet you and i was looking at your story
and you
you are an anomaly in so many ways
because
um you're you're incredibly self-aware
and conscious now and clearly that's not
always been the case when you're in that
pre-breakdown phase similar with me i
wasn't i was i was a
puppet driven by society society was the
puppet master in my insecurities from my
childhood but you've reached that point
of like self-awareness that you know
those goals aren't going to matter and
that you know why you're doing it you
know that balance is key and you're able
to allocate your time in accordance with
your long-term values not any sort of
external or insecure um
[Music]
goals or desires so i think that's
remarkable and i think the reason why i
wrote my book and a lot of the reason
why i do this podcast is to share
stories like yours so thank you for your
time it is an honor to spend this time
with you and uh
i am really excited to see you become
synonymous with um tech across the world
and i think you're i mean you're clearly
on the way to doing that remarkable what
you've achieved i appreciate it and as a
small little irrelevant youtuber
i'm gonna i'm gonna need some tips from
you off camera about how i can uh
continue to do what i'm doing but to be
fair like you've answered it for me like
we enjoy it
and uh yeah we we celebrate like the
little wins and stuff but we're doing
this i think i think i speak for the
team because like meeting people like
you and doing this is fun
i'll give you one little nugget now
more than one if you have them
i would try and add some structure
interesting i think a lot of the people
watching this podcast are very ambitious
people who who want the next thing
and i think your videos could
potentially highlight what's coming and
with some sort of ramping intensity
to
keep those kinds of ambitious people who
want the next thing engaged interesting
have you watched hot ones
yes the wings the wings show yeah and
the reason it's so interesting is that
you know the wings are getting hotter
each time
and that structure allows me to just
like watch right till the end no matter
what they're talking about that's really
really good feedback because
watch time matters is so critical to
youtube right in the algorithm so
incentivizing people when they in the
first five minutes to stay till minute
55 by letting them know there's
something spicy over there
um no pun intended
makes a lot a lot a lot of sense yeah
i'm going to speak to jack who's behind
me
we're going to figure out a way to
conduct that experiment yeah any other
tips before i go like i know you've
looked at my youtube channel and you
thought what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
one uh one thing i've started thinking
about recently actually is uh you can
just say it was something you saw
i did a big watch through of the marvel
films okay start to finish the whole
universe
and i realized that like these movies
are um
they are self-contained episodes so you
can watch one end to end and you will
get a character arc you will get
villains and heroes and the heroes will
beat the villains but they're also part
of a bigger picture
and it made me realize that like every
time i finished one of them i wanted to
watch the next one
because it was all contributing to this
bigger picture it was like this this
bigger universe
and so more and more i'm starting to
think of like my videos as contributions
to a universe
and how to actually link between them in
ways that people feel like they need to
watch all of them or no no more like
they want to watch all of them to get
the full
the full picture
so oftentimes now i will actually have
inter video jokes
things that actually span multiple
videos like i've had one where i
finished one video by throwing a phone
up in the air and i caught it in the
next one
i've had other times where
between three sets of videos someone
started throwing stuff at me during the
videos with increasing intensity
and these kinds of like multi-video
storylines are actually really really
powerful
again because of the algorithm right
yeah i mean it just makes people want to
watch you more
it makes it feel not complete by just
watching one video i met youtube and
youtube said to me that um
when people go on a streak of watching
multiple videos on youtube and you'll
know that i was like i don't know why
i'm talking to you about [ __ ] youtube
tips but they said to me when people go
on a streak of watching multiple videos
on youtube then the first video in that
street gets the credit basically so if
you can create content that is episodic
then it will all of the videos will
perform better so what you're talking
about there is kind of like interlinking
narratives throughout multiple videos
so that one video doesn't stand alone
you have to
yeah that's really interesting but
listen thank you for your time i've had
so much of it and it's um it's a huge
honor i don't know how busy you are so
it's a huge honor that you've given some
of your allocation today to this because
i know you're someone that understands
the value of your time so i really
really appreciate you and i'm i don't
have to tell people where to find you
um you're welcome to never i mean
type in your name anywhere and they'll
find find you in your work on every
social platform thank you aaron it's
been a huge pleasure it's been
incredible thanks steve
[Music]
you